hello there I'm gay I'm Dan where the
slow mo guys it should be a nice simple
video how fast is glass crack I actually
don't know but we did that one video
with the pirates jerk where we saw it
yeah it was actually quite difficult to
figure out the speed because the the
crack was going through a curved Pyrex
jug handle was about this big it's
almost like we need a really long piece
of glass with foot markers on it where
could we get one of those you think oh
okay so here's one look at this I wonder
what this is doing it so in theory if we
break this at one end the crack should
rush through it I'm gonna put foot lines
on it and we'll be able to determine the
exact speed of a glass break what's done
here with our 7-foot piece of glass is
I've spray-painted exactly a foot along
the glass now a foots gonna start and
from the cameras point of view the
left-hand side of the blue so this edge
is gonna be exactly a foot from here and
this one's gonna be that different from
here etc so you should be able to
calculate the exact speed for glass as
we know we need very high speeds the
front of flex 4k only does a thousand
frames a second not worth it might see a
couple of frames maybe if that we've got
the 2512 here today we usually use the
25:11 this is the next revision has a
difference than you make a much bigger
internal memory but other than that it's
the same camera so we'll start at 28,000
500 frames a second but never written
this oh yeah you're telling me right you
stand there a bit of foam so you've got
there for protection
yeah protect the glass so they sort of
smash before already oh cool so hold it
here
okay you got it I think so I'm gonna bug
in a ton of shutter here 45 degrees
oh that's noise you never do that why do
you know in it let me just grip this
with this and see if I can smash the
glass with just a pair of pliers babe go
for it
that works not really what Oh just
vanished God I didn't expect to be able
to do that and then he just went oh you
really framed up on the edges aren't you
yep three two one step oh cool that's
really no I'm surprised you can even see
that much with the 28,000 yeah it's
because it's so big this is our starting
frame rate we plan on going much faster
I also like the fact that if I speed up
a bit
it's like irrelevant of gravity it
splits up and down at the same time
because I guess the pressure being
released just goes with it also shot
forwards and at me once it when you
crack it it sort of explodes yeah that's
why it makes that like sort of sound or
it pops because it like has the pressure
built up I guess I did this with pain
instead of tape oh yeah yeah you could
see it separating you can actually kind
of see where everything was even in the
air it stays jagged directly in line
underneath each other faster oh yeah
so the way you can increase the
framerate on the phantom cameras is you
just lower the resolution and as you may
have noticed the top on the bottom of
the frame here a complete garbage nor a
waste so what I can do is keep the width
the same but lower the vertical
resolution so maybe something like that
and that way we're keeping all of the
useful area but it will give us the
chance to go to yep 63 get some a darker
probably not much sure to compensate
should be so this time I'll get some
different colors in the go yeah I'm
gonna start by spraying each foot marker
with a different color painting with den
yeh I'm just gonna get on the table here
are in a rush they
that's read done I like that you're
doing this across two tables so you rank
both at once I won't enjoy that lovely
so the right-hand side of these or your
left will be a foot long this is pretty
satisfying slop it in there when you get
a chance okay let me try and fill the
frame with this mad lad go for it my
level
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay Dan it's time for some maths versus
I'm gonna get up the true time of this
crack and we'll measure how long in
seconds it took each foot to break
there's a slight discrepancy between
each one just because of which side of
the foot mark of the crack landed on
that particular frame but don't worry
will a ver each term out more Matt
giving us average time of point zero
zero two seconds per foot which is forty
seven hundred and fifty eight feet per
second and for the international
audiences that's 1,450 M years per
second 3262 miles per hour
5250 km/h or mac 4.20 you know my mind
is blown I don't think that there's
anything that's like physical but that's
quick what's physical that that's
quickly what goes Mac 4.2 apart from
spaceship it's almost it's weird how
like none of it overtakes anything else
like okay so it starts as round right
see that it's not rounded yeah so the
middle of the glass is actually ahead of
the sides but it catches up and then
it's all just going in a line do you
know I think right that is not I don't
expect to see there I think it what it
looks like is if this was actually a
circle like if it was like a 14 foot
circle yeah and you smashed the middle
it would all go out in a circle but
we're just seeing like a section of that
so if you imagine that it starts off as
a small circle it gets bigger and bigger
it doesn't it's not actually flat when
he gets the end it's still slightly
curved so I'm just imagining a circle
getting bigger therefore the edge is
getting flatter yeah exactly
bloody mental now can't want to do it a
big circle fresh out of 14-foot glass
circles unfortunately good church window
alright so that was 78,000
multi-coloured yeah I think it's time to
get carried away
this bad boys the capable of some
serious let's Lincoln let's let it
stretch this legs
thank you every spin will reduce the
horizontal width as well lose some more
on the vehicle maybe go to five six by
ninety six that's small enough giving us
a frame rate over four hundred and
eighty one and a half thousand frames a
second because we're now so cropped in
I'm only gonna be seeing two colors so
there's no point painting the rest waste
the paint waste a paint glass is cool Oh
ridiculous how much can you see bloody
stupid this is she's that one pot let's
look at this ridiculousness
it just looks like a software wipe it's
just like we took two fixes then just
wiped across it just instantly turns it
to like lizard skin just turns into like
scales this cameras so cool just records
all that like that happened and it
recorded it at that yeah this camera saw
everything final aftermath another
pretty aftermath that is not bad it
sounds like snow - listen don't like
snow but what's cool is the fact that
cuz obviously we did it all in in color
order it's all stayed there and look
this is all this looks like it's an
intact piece of glass but it's actually
oh yeah at least smash it's gone it's
just held together by there yeah which
is why it was good that lab we didn't
record the the paint side who recorded
the front side so you can see the
cracking around the color well we
learned the speed that a crack
propagates through laminated sheet of
glass yeah they've temp in action you
couldn't tell with the the little video
we did before but that really
demonstrated it was so fast and and the
way it starts as a circle and then
basically gets bigger for in a circle
even though it's a flat rectangular
piece of glass I was really impressed by
that I didn't I didn't expect to see
that I guess you'd never know it unless
you see a long piece of glass slow
motion in my head
you were gonna crack it and it would
just come across as a straight ball the
whole way of outside oh of course it's
gonna crack from that point and then the
fact that it evened out was very cool to
me yeah it was awesome hopefully you
enjoyed that video bung it alike if you
did there's a dislike button - that's
always fun subscribe to the slow mo guys
and we've got a second channel any
closing thoughts Daniel gets a bear get
a broomis will get a get a broom yep for
this got this grass glass grass grow I
met grass that time okay yeah because
I'm gonna sweep up the glass from the
grass yeah